thank you very much mr president i am
truly humbled by the extraordinary honor
of this nomination
and i am especially grateful for the
care that you have taken in discharging
your constitutional duty in service of
our democracy with all that is going on
in the world today
i also offer my sincerest thanks to you
as well madam vice president
for your invaluable role
in this nomination process
i must begin these very brief remarks by
thanking god
for delivering me
to this point in my professional journey
my life has been blessed beyond measure
and i do know
that one can only come this far
by faith
among my many blessings and indeed the
very first is the fact
that i was born in this great country
the united states of america is the
greatest beacon of hope and democracy
the world has ever known
i was also blessed from my early days to
have had a supportive and loving family
my mother and father
who have been married for 54 years
are at their home in florida right now
and i know that they could not be more
proud
it was my father who started me on this
path
when i was a child as
the president mentioned
my father made the fateful decision to
transition
from his job as a public high school
history teacher and go to law school
some of my earliest memories are of him
sitting at the kitchen table reading his
law books
i watched him study
and he became my first professional role
model
my mother who was also a public high
school teacher provided invaluable
support in those early days working
full-time to enable my father's career
transition while also guiding and
inspiring four-year-old me
my only sibling my brother kitaj
came along half a decade later
and i'm so proud of all that he's
accomplished
after graduating from howard university
he became a police officer and a
detective on some of the toughest
streets in the inner city of baltimore
after that he enlisted
in the army
serving two tours of duty in the middle
east
i believe that he was following the
example set by my uncles who are in law
enforcement you may have read
that i have one uncle who got caught up
in the drug trade
and received a life sentence that is
true
but law enforcement also runs in my
family in addition to my brother i had
two uncles who served decades as police
officers one of whom
became the police chief in my hometown
of miami florida
i am standing here today by the grace of
god as testament to the love and support
that i've received from my family
i have also been blessed with many dear
friends colleagues mentors law clerks
i could not possibly name all of the
people to whom i owe great thanks
but i must mention specifically the
three brilliant jurists
for whom i had the privilege of serving
as a law clerk at the outset of my legal
career
u.s district judge patty cerris in
massachusetts
u.s court of appeals bruce judge bruce
celia in rhode island
and last but certainly not least
associate justice stephen breyer of the
supreme court of the united states
justice breyer in particular
not only gave me the greatest job that
any young lawyer could ever hope to have
but he also exemplified
every day in every way
that a supreme court justice can perform
at the highest level of skill and
integrity while also being guided by
civility
grace
pragmatism
and generosity of spirit
justice breyer
the members of the senate will decide if
i fill your seat
but please know
that i could never
fill your shoes
to my dear family
those who are here with me now and those
who are watching from home i am forever
indebted to you for your love and
support
to my beloved husband patrick
thank you for being my rock today and
every day for this these past 26 years i
love you
to my daughters talia and laila you are
the light of my life
please know
that whatever title i may hold or
whatever job i may have
i will still be your mom
that will never change
there are so many other people i would
love to be able to address and to thank
but time is short so let me end
by sharing an interesting coincidence
that has actually meant a great deal to
me over the years
as it happens
i share a birthday
with the first black woman ever to be
appointed as a federal judge
the honorable constance baker motley
we were born exactly 49 years to the day
apart
today i proudly stand on judge motley's
shoulders
sharing not only her birthday
but also her steadfast and courageous
commitment to equal justice under law
judge motley's life and career has been
a true inspiration to me
as i have pursued this professional path
and if i'm fortunate enough to be
confirmed as the next associates justice
of the supreme court of the united
states
i can only hope that my life and career
my love of this country and the
constitution
and my commitment to upholding the rule
of law and the sacred principles upon
which this great nation was founded
will inspire future generations of
americans
thank you again mr president for this
extraordinary honor
[Applause]
i forgot to introduce the first lady dr
jill biden
and the second gentleman i said seems
strange to say that but the second doug
is emhoff they're both here as well so
thank you thank you all
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else